hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Marvel Civil War 2 video I'll be
talking about issue 2 careful for
spoilers if you haven't read it yet
also be talking about totally awesome
Hulk that title so the big WTF and
Marvel's new Civil War event is the idea
that the Hulk is going to kill the
Marvel Universe I know I was just
talking about Deadpool kills the Marvel
Universe which is like a completely
separate event Hulk smashing the Marvel
Universe might remind you of world war
hulk from several years ago or even
Planet Hulk so quick backstory to create
some context in Civil War there's a
Minority Report inhuman that can predict
the future or seems like he can predict
the future
he gets visions and thus far most people
are treating it like the actual future
like oh my god this is going to happen
we have to do something to prevent it
Tony Stark on the other side of this
conflict is saying hey listen this might
be a self-fulfilling prophecy situation
wherein these visions that he has might
not be the future they might just be a
potential future and by taking action to
try and stop that we might wind up
bringing about that very vision that he
saw so self-fulfilling prophecy now he's
got a vision of the Hulk killing
everyone all the Avengers all the heroes
everyone on both sides of this Civil War
conflict so Captain Marvel's like we
have to do something about this she
immediately jets off and shows up in
Bruce banners lab and he's like oh hey
hello how are you doing he hasn't really
been a part of the conflict thus far
I'll post a link to the video I did for
the first issue that explains why Tony
Stark and Captain Marvel are going at it
but the inhuman gets a vision Captain
Marvel just immediately snapped judgment
jets off to go take down Bruce Banner
before he has a chance to kill everyone
the problem is is that Bruce Banner is
not the Hulk in the Marvel Universe
right now it's Amadeus Cho
so sidestepping to the whole comic books
if you haven't been reading Hulk since
Secret Wars what happened is his Amadeus
Cho absorbed all of Bruce banners gamma
in this big accident but in doing so he
became the Hulk himself so the Hulk is
now Amadeus Cho he's kind of like this
teenage cocky super-smart swagger Hulk
so the name of the comic book is totally
awesome Hulk it's just a lighter take on
the whole character it's actually a lot
of fun but the big WTF now isn't so much
the Hulk killing the Marvel Universe
it's not knowing which hook it is
is this whole Bruce Banner or is this
Amadeus Cho they purposefully drew this
pantsless version of hawk we'll talk
about that in a sec he's not wearing
pants WTF but they purposefully drew his
head really small and frame here with
his junk way up and framed so that you
couldn't really make out who he was
so the oh cliffhanger is Captain
Marvel looking like she's going to take
down Bruce Banner without really
understanding whether or not he's the
Hulk right now it does a really good job
of presenting Tony Stark's position on
the whole thing like hey wait you know
we shouldn't jump the gun on these
visions they might not be what they seem
Tony Stark captures the inhuman tries to
study his brain to learn more about how
the visions work whereas Captain Marvel
is accepting the visions as fact she's
like oh my god I just saw the Hulk kill
the Marvel Universe we have to stop
Bruce Banner without really doing the
detective work you need to do in a
situation like this so here's my first
big question for you guys which version
of the Hulk do you think this is do you
think it's Amadeus Cho who is currently
the Hulk in the Marvel Universe or do
you think it's actually Bruce Banner
there's more evidence I'll say there's
more evidence based on what the comics
are doing right now to say that it's
Amadeus Cho but we haven't really seen
him in this Civil War story that much so
we don't really know what his character
is doing at this moment I feel like it'd
be more tragic because he's such an
innocent character he's like a teenager
like Peter Parker getting the powers of
spider-man great power great
responsibility Amadeus Cho gets the
powers of the Hulk but doesn't
necessarily take it as seriously as
Bruce Banner the Hulk is both a blessing
and a curse and a lot of the drama with
Bruce banners character in his comics
over the last 50 plus years has been
like the dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde struggle in
that Bruce Banner is a good person wants
to do good things is a member of the
Avengers but he almost has zero control
of himself when he is the Hulk
so collateral damage is a big problem
Amadeus Cho is just learning about this
and they've kind of teased it in his
comic the first couple times he becomes
the Hulk he just slowly starts to Hulk
out a little bit then calms himself down
but he still treats it like it's a bit
of a joke like he's not taking it as
seriously as he probably should so
that's why I feel like it'd be a bigger
WTF if Amadeus Cho killed the Marvel
Universe like that's what this vision is
saying even though I don't think this is
going to come to pass
they'll kill a couple more big
characters during the Civil War comic
but there's no way
they're gonna kill every single hero so
if you haven't started reading it yet
and you're still like I have no idea
what's going on I'm so confused just be
sure to read civil war it's actually a
lot of fun the biggest comic books I'm
reading right now our international
Ironman invincible Iron Man which is
just phenomenal
Civil War 2 DC's rebirth and flash
rebirth so I do read way more than that
but those are typically the ones I read
first and the ones I follow week to week
sidestepping two No Pants 2 if you look
at this first issue of totally awesome
Hulk he forgets to wear his stretchy
Hulk pants so when he hooks out big
green mean for everyone to see so I feel
like this image is mirroring that just a
little more evidence that it might be
Amadeus Cho forgot to wear my stretchy
Hulk pants the day I killed the Marvel
Universe but summer hype train pulling
out of the station Hulk smashes the
Marvel Universe be sure to check it out
and if you guys haven't watched
daredevil season 2 yet be sure to check
that out because I mean I have done some
videos for it it dropped away earlier
this year but it's important homework
for what's going on on arrow season 5
I'm gonna be doing an arrow video next
so be sure to subscribe to get that but
they have a character coming on who has
an arc that's very much like The
Punisher so I'll explain what's going on
with that show because they're actually
making some huge changes to arrow it's
not gonna look anything like it has in
the last couple of seasons which I think
that most of you guys will enjoy but
there's a whole bunch of Game of Thrones
coming on Sunday tomorrow - so arrow
later tonight then Game of Thrones
tomorrow I know it seems like there
isn't a whole lot happening right now
but there is so much stuff going on
so why you guys wait for my next video
to post you can click here to learn all
about the flash season 3 episode 1 and
you can click here for like my last big
Civil War video explaining what's going
on thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight
you